what do people not understand about  anxiety it's something that I feel is  very complex especially for women  because I know like if my progesterone's  low I literally I told my husband it was  like two days ago I was in right after  ovulation again I'm like I looked at him  and I'm like if you could be in my head  right now it's like hell  I was like it's like hell like when  you're progesterone you know I'm making  enough progesterone like my I get body  anxiety to wear everything in me  vibrates it's like someone plugged me  into a wall socket and it is no matter  what I do I can breathe I can meditate I  can do all the things but nothing works  and I think  you know there's all these tools that we  have and at some point sometimes nothing  works and I think the people around us  have to be compassionate to that